data in this episode
our team of young digital experts sets
out to explore how data travels across
the old continent
on their sightseeing agenda data-driven
sites and landmarks
from connected farms with sensor
equipped livestock
to wind farms using industrial data to
generate
more power blows my mind their
conclusion
is unanimous data is everywhere
and it's changing the way stuff works
the eu is looking into ways to improve
lives thanks to data
sharing data anonymously which will feed
into thematic data spaces
means getting better tailored services
which in turn
make your life easier it will bring
enormous benefits to you
but also to companies and ultimately to
society as a whole
i told you so guys check your traffic
apps
monitoring traffic flows will improve
public transport
with health data safely gathered curing
rare diseases will become a reality
and monitoring energy consumption data
will allow to save
energy and help the planet and thanks to
a clear set of rules and good data
protection
everyone's data will be safe if we get
this right
the data economy could be worth up to
829 billion euros in 2025
a new currency of sorts paying by cash
or card
oh that will be data